so sometimes it feels like users are
from Earth and monetization is from Mars
what do we know about users we know that
most of them favor free apps in 2014
over ninety percent of the apps that
were downloaded with free apps users
wish to avoid paying upfront but they
don't mind pain in the right moment when
they see the value in front of the eyes
this is the reason most up are using
in-app payments okay so users prefer
free apps but they don't mind paying
once the app proves its value so besides
in-app purchases what other models do we
have we have many monetization options
in a billing you can sell digital goods
and real good to your users from the
free app in-app payments you let your
user purchase item level points special
tools from your app adds we got lots of
options with different types like
display advertising in text links videos
and many more the important thing to
note here is that you wish to blend the
ad into your experience and not to
interrupt it another opportunity is with
affiliate you could make money by
referring to other services and there's
lots of other models that you might want
to check if there are appropriate to
your case email campaigns selling data
auction flash sales merchandising
premium support and many more that's a
lot of models I mean how do you know
that you're choosing the right one it's
a real challenge we will provide more
information that will help you get to
those answers in the next lessons one
thing to take from this lesson is that
your goal is to deliver the right
monetization to the right user at the
right time